director david lowry the filmmaker
behind a ghost story the old man and the
gun
and ain't them body saints has teamed
with a24 for the highly anticipated epic
fantasy film the green knight
here's everything we know about the
movie so far
david lowry has been in the
entertainment business for nearly three
decades now doing
everything from acting and editing to
working as a second unit director
producer and cinematographer before
finally writing and directing his own
movies
his featured directorial debut came in
2009 with the release of saint nick and
from there
lowry has written and directed a handful
of films from his critically acclaimed
original projects as a writer director
to more traditional studio fair like the
remake of pete's dragon he's also
attached as the co-writer and director
of 2022's live-action peter pan and
wendy film according to variety
basically lowry is a powerhouse in
hollywood so it makes sense that
following the critical success of his
2017 movie a ghost story
a24 wanted to recreate the magic in
november 2018 deadline announced that
a24 had partnered with vowery for the
green knight
the movie is described as a fantasy epic
retelling of the 14th century chivalric
story sir
wayne and the green knight written by an
anonymous author known as gawain poet or
less commonly the pearl poet named after
a poem also included in the sole
existing gawain manuscript
a24 tapped leyline entertainment and
bronze studios to co-finance the film
which was reportedly made on a very low
budget according to entertainment weekly
though exact numbers haven't been made
publicly available either way
from the teasers and trailers alone the
movie looks like a sumptuous stark
vision
regardless of what it costs the results
are undeniably
impressive before we keep talking about
how
the green knight is an adaptation of the
sir gawain and the green knights story
we should make sure that everyone knows
what that story even is
without spoiling any of the big reveals
and trust us there are some major ones
here's an abridged plot summary of the
famous 14th century tale
sir wayne and the green knight centers
around king arthur's erstwhile nephew
sir gawain a largely untested knight of
camelot's famed round table
sir gawain unexpectedly accepts a life
or death challenge from the monstrous
titular green knight
according to the green knights game a
challenger may attempt to strike the
green knight but
only on the condition that they must
again face the green knight a year later
sir gawain beheads the green knights who
supernaturally survives the ordeal
then embarks on a sprawling mind-melting
journey to honor his side of the deal
along the way sir gawain and the green
knights becomes an odyssey-styled epic
as sir wayne's honor
valor and metal are repeatedly
proclaimed questioned and tested
there's a lot more going on within the
narrative that the green knight is sure
to unravel on the big screen but
delving too much into the plot would
stand the chance of spoiling things
if you want to get all the nitty gritty
details hold out for what david lowry
and a24 are offering in their adaptation
of the green knight
david lowry's the green knight is
actually the third theatrically released
film adaptation of sir
wayne in the green knight coming after
1973's gawain and the green knight and
1984's sword of the valiant
the legend of sir wayne and the green
knight both of which were written and
directed by filmmaker stephen weeks
there have also been tv movie
adaptations of the story as well
including a 1991 british live-action
production and a 2002 bafta
award-winning animated short
done in the style of stained glass
windows in the first stephen weeks movie
murray head played gawain and nigel
green portrayed the green knight
in the second miles o'keefe was sir
wayne and sean connery was the green
knight
although the new film uses a
centuries-old piece of literature as its
source material and isn't the first
adaptation of that material at all
the green knight promises to breathe new
life into the tale
and not just because the r-rated film
will feature violence
some sexuality and graphic nudity when
crafting the green knight lowry found
inspiration and fantasy movies from the
1980s horror flicks
the works of william shakespeare and
more as he told entertainment weekly in
an exclusive interview
in terms of visual references we looked
at everything from
andre rublev which is i think one of the
greatest movies ever made
and which you can never make now we
looked at willow the ron howard film
which is one of my favorite fantasy
films of all time
we looked at a lot of 80s fantasy to be
honest like lady hawk and dragon slayer
and willow
lowry was also influenced by the horror
films produced by hammerfilm productions
a seven-hour long russian adaptation of
war and peace from the 1960s that had
recently been restored just as the green
knight began pre-production
kenneth branagh's henry v and tons of
shakespeare classics
the filmmaker affirmed that the green
knight is completely a fantasy and that
there's quote no historical accuracy to
the film
whatsoever so don't go looking for this
movie if you're wanting to see a
realistic rendering of medieval times
for all you history buffs out there
maybe wait to see the movie until it's
available on streaming
so that you don't bother anybody while
you're yelling at the screen
when the green knights does battle with
some of 2021's biggest movies and the
mammoth promotional budgets of the major
studios who produce them
it will do so with the help of a
first-rate cast at the head of the pack
playing lead character sir gawain is
oscar-nominated actor dev patel who has
recently received praise and accolades
in droves for his turns in slumdog
millionaire
chappie the best exotic marigold hotel
the personal history of david
copperfield and
more according to variety patel joined
the cast of the green knight in march
2019
that same month the casting of ralph
einstein was also announced with reports
confirming his role as the green knight
viewers may recognize einstein from his
work as amicus cairo in three of the
eight harry potter movies
chris finch in the uk version of the
office nikolai tarakanov and hbo's
chernobyl miniseries and also william in
another masterful a24 movie
the witch academy award winner alicia
vikander joins the leading duo as lady
birdilock
the wife of lord bertilak to otizert
played in the green knight by prolific
australian actor joel edgerton
rounding out the cast are shawn harris
as king arthur kate dickey is queen
guinevere
the falcon and the winter soldier star
aaron kellyman cerita chowdhury and
barry keuin
the irish film and television network
reported that production on the green
knight kicked off in march 2019 and
listed two of the movie's filming
locations
ardmore studios in bray county wicklow
ireland and cair castle located in
county tippery ireland
films like 1974's bizarre sci-fi fantasy
zardaz 1995's legendary historical war
epic
braveheart 2004's king arthur and 2012's
byzantium have filmed at ardmore studios
as have the television series the tudors
penny dreadful camelot into the badlands
reign
and the irish version of dancing with
the stars as 4k
castle it's been used for projects like
1981's excalibur and the television
series the tudors
according to hn entertainment acclaimed
new zealand-based digital visual effects
company weda digital spearheaded the
effects for the green knight
what a digital's eric sanden told the
outlet about some of the many plates the
company was spinning in april 2019
sharing we're back on the avatar movies
now and we're even doing a project with
david lowry called
green knight which is another fun
project and just something on the
opposite
end of the budget of avatar but still
another fun script
in a chat with entertainment weekly
david lowry gushed about the experience
of filming the green knight
he told the outlet we had one day that
was one of the most
fun days that i've ever had on set it
just felt like
i'm here in ireland with my friends
making one of the coolest movies we
could ever possibly make
it wasn't all perfect though lowry did
say that he ended up getting
really sick during filming which on top
of the stress of filming a movie was a
bit of a
nightmare but he powered through once
the green knights completed principal
photography the next order of business
was post-production on route to a
festival debut and then a formal
theatrical release
on march 2nd 2020 deadline announced
that the green knight would make its
world premiere in austin texas at the
south by southwest festival
the official premiere date was set to be
on friday march 16th ahead of a more
robust theatrical launch on friday may
29th
anyway you all know what we're about to
tell you as literally just about
everyone in the world knows march 2020
was the time at which kova 19
already spreading rapidly across the
globe finally started to upset the world
order by causing
everything from broadway to the olympics
to movie premieres worldwide to get shut
down
and delayed indefinitely we all know by
now how the rest of 2020 shook out but
deadline at the time reported an
optimistic outlook saying that south by
southwest would indeed be moving forward
despite industry panic about the
coronavirus according to the outlet the
organizers of the 2020 festival were
committed to taking any necessary
precautions to make the festival as safe
as possible but the situation developed
rapidly four days after deadlines report
and less than
two weeks before the intended premiere
of the green night
the festival organizers announced that
the event was canceled the film also
lost its may 29
2020 release date as a result of the
coven 19 pandemic shutting down theaters
and a24 kept
the green knight in limbo for months
until it finally set a new debut date
one year
hence in december 2020
seven months after the mines behind the
green knight had their dreams
dashed following the cancellation of
2020 south by southwest festival
a24 went public with its new game plan
the movie would become an unlikely
summer blockbuster debuting in theaters
on july 30
2021 without any prior appearances at
smaller more
exclusive film festivals as was
originally intended
a quick crunching of the numbers
indicates that this entire series of
setbacks works out to a total delay of
16 and a half months from the time
audiences were originally meant to start
seeing the green knight and the actual
date when it's set to open in a wide
release
if nothing else you can tell from the
youtube comments on the movies teaser
originally posted in february 2020 that
people have been eagerly awaiting the
movie
and letting people know about it
throughout the entirety of the long
pandemic
with such a stacked cast and a story
filled with mystery and
intrigue though the green knight is sure
to reward viewers for their patience
blowing everyone away when it at long
last hits silver screens this summer
as the old adage goes good things come
to those who wait
a24 is known for being low-key when it
comes to marketing its movies
preferring to let the films speak for
themselves instead of doing any heavy
over-the-top promotion the green knight
has continued to make headlines despite
not having a massive marketing campaign
behind it almost entirely thanks to the
caliber of its creative talent in front
of and behind
the camera and what movie fans have seen
of the film so far has them excited
beyond belief
the green knight has made it onto
several lists of outlets most
anticipated movies of 2021 with observer
stamping it as a must-see summer movie
over on twitter users have expressed
their excitement for the green knight
with the kind of quippy
unrestrained posts characteristic of the
platform one poster confessed
yo i can't stop watching the latest
trailer for the green knight
i'm so hyped another confessed that they
haven't been excited about movies in
quite some time but the thought of
seeing the green knight in theaters
made them feel those warm fuzzies again
writing
this is the first time in a long time i
got excited with an upcoming release
and that's on the green knight whether
you've known about the green knights
story or you've just learned it from
this movie it's hard
not to be excited about this dark and
epic fable
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
upcoming movies and tv shows are coming
soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one